Game of Thrones has a huge rotating cast
of course we can't expect everyone to
stick around for every episode but
sometimes characters go missing and in
some cases four seasons on end here's
five characters who are currently m.i.a
the sand snakes of dawn weren't the most
popular with fans of the show when we
last left them at the beginning of
season six they'd just staged a coup
they murdered Prince Doran aunt ro
stayin there for killing the Martell
family line
they also murdered Marcella Baratheon to
get revenge on the Lannisters for
killing Oberyn Martell book fans were
particularly pissed as pretty much the
exact opposite happens in George RR
Martin's tomes the sands eggs plan to
crown Mesilla to rival Tommen and it
turns out that Prince Doran has been a
lifelong Targaryen loyalists who has
spent years plotting revenge against the
Lannisters olaria actually aims for
peace as she fears for her daughter's
lives but instead in the show she ends
up doing this
originally the TV show wasn't even going
to go to dawn it ended up being hastily
added made no sense and therefore got
completely slated we haven't seen the
sand snakes in a long time we may not
see them again
Aya's died wolf Nymeria was named after
the warrior queen from ancient dawn and
she was a little warrior herself she got
into a scrap with Joffrey way back in
season one my Maria ran away after the
confrontation so Sansa's died wolf lady
ended up getting it in the neck
literally my Mira is currently running
around the Riverlands
so could all you be reunited with
another hound at some point in the
future Gendry the expert blacksmith /
Baratheon bastard man has been m.i.a
since the end of season 3 he's had quite
the adventure so far though he almost
went to the wall almost joined the
Brotherhood without banners
he got sold to the Lord of Lights number
one fan Melisandre for 2 whole bags of
gold which is quite a lot he then got
seduced by Melisandre but then she stole
some of his blood kinky and since his
blood is the precious commodity King's
blood he has something of a target on
his back so said Davos put him in a
rowboat and sent him off to King's
Landing however the poor lad can't swim
and isn't exactly great at rowing either
so whether he made it or not is
completely up in the air don't fall out
Warner beric Dondarrion the leader of
the Brotherhood without banners and
Thoris of Maia the red priests have been
m.i.a since the end of season 3 after
Berek duels with the Hound in a trial by
combat he's chopped almost in half by
clique gains brute strength he's
resurrected by Thoris tho who uses the
power of the Lord of Light their last
seen selling Gendry to Melisandre but a
recent casting leak suggests that they
may be back in season 6 and finally our
favorite feline companion sir pounce
he's been gone a long time and we really
fear for his safety
please come back ser pounce please
Joffrey didn't like him he threatened to
skin him alive mix his innards up in my
food so I wouldn't know was eating him
so there's a handful of characters who
are completely m.i.a in Game of Thrones
will we see any this season let me know
in the comments below for more videos
like this make
to head over to youtube.com slash
GameSpot all men must subscribe